this is what esah Hamed's home in Kum
looks like after an artillery shell hit
it last week residents here say it came
from across the Nile River fired by the
paramilitary rapid support forces into
Northern umur man a stronghold of the
Sudanese Army the two sides have been
fighting for more than 6
months I was sitting on the bed then I
heard an explosion and I was covered in
dust I couldn't move because of the
destraction and the shno hit me in the
leg I was bleeding they took me to the
neighbor's house and that's where I
found out it was an artery
strike once a relatively safe place in
the past month hundreds of artillery
strikes have been launched at schools
hospitals and homes in Northern omdurman
dozens of civilians have been killed or
injured I was coming back from the shop
and heard people saying that are falling
one hit our neighbor and killed him I
was hit by shrapnel we ran home and the
second round struck our house local
emergency crews accused the rapid
support forces of carrying out the
strikes the shelling in civilian areas
has prompted people who had stayed in
Harum throughout the months of conflict
to leave to safer areas outside the
capital but in the past few weeks
fighting and insecurity has been
spreading to previously safe
areas ceasefire talks have resumed after
months of suspension both the Sudanese
Army and the paramilitary group say they
want to end the suffering of those
caught in the crossfire but previous
trues collapsed sometimes minutes after
coming into effect and many here say
they'll wait to see if this round of
negotiations is any different hio Morgan
Al jazer
Kum make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer